so we've got the function f of X is
equal to two x to the third plus five x
squared minus seven all of that to the
eighth power and we want to find the
derivative of our function f with
respect to X now the key here is to
realize that this function can be viewed
as a composition of two functions how do
we do that well let me diagram it out so
let's say we want to start with I'll do
it down here so I have some space so
we're gonna start with an X and what's
the first thing that we would do if you
were just trying to evaluate it given
some X well the first thing you would
take 2 times that X to the third power
plus 5 times that x squared and then
minus 7 so what if we imagined a a
function here that just did that first
part that just evaluated X just
evaluated to X to the third plus 5 x
squared minus 7 for your X so let's call
that the function U and so whatever you
input into that function u you're gonna
get 2 times that input to the third
power plus 5 times that input to the
second power minus 7 and so when you do
that when you input with an X what do
you output
what do you output here well you're
going to output U of X U of X which is
equal to 2x to the third power plus 5 x
squared minus 7 and I'll do it all in
one color just so I don't have to keep
changing colors so 2x to the third power
plus 5 x squared minus 7 that is U of X
now what's the next thing you're doing
you're not done evaluating f of X yet
you would then take that value and then
input it into another function you would
then take the 8th power of that value so
then we will take that and input it into
another function that let's call that
function V and that function whatever
input you give it and I'm using these
squares is to say whatever input goes
into that function you are going to take
it to the 8th power and so in this case
what do you get what do you end up with
well you end up with V of U of X V of U
of X or you could view this as V of 2x
to the third to X to the third plus 5 x
squared minus 7 or you could view this
two x to the third plus five x squared
minus seven all of that to the eighth
power all of that to the eighth power
and that's what f of X is so as we just
saw f of X can be viewed as the
composition of V and u this is f of X so
if we write f of X if we write f of X
being equal to V of U of X U of X then
we see very clearly the chain rule is
very useful here the chain rule tells us
that F prime of X is going to be the
derivative of V with respect to U so
it's going to be V prime of not X but V
prime of U of X the derivative of V with
respect to U times the derivative of U
with respect to X so u prime of X so we
know we know a few things already so
let's let me just write things down very
clearly so we know that U of X is equal
to 2x to the 3rd power plus 5x squared
minus 7 what is U prime of X well here
we're just going to use some derivative
properties in the power rule 3 times 2
is 6 X 3 minus 1 is 2 6x squared 2 times
5 is 10 take one off that exponent it's
going to be 10 X to the first power or
just 10 X and the derivative of a
constant is just zero so we can just
ignore that
so that's u prime of X now we know that
V if we input an X into V so V of X
would be equal to X to the 8th power V
prime of X well we just use the power
rule again that's 8x to the seventh
power and so V prime of U of X so if you
were to input U of X into V prime well
it's going to be equal to it is going to
be equal to 8 times U of X to the
seventh power
whatever you input into V Prime you're
gonna mult you can take it to the
seventh power and multiply it by 8 so
you
of X and that's the same thing that is
the same day this is equal to eight
times this entire expression U of X is
2x to the third power 2x to the third
power plus five x squared minus seven so
there you have it f prime of X it is
equal to this which we just figured out
V prime of U of X is all of this
business so it's equal to eight eight
times two x to the third plus five x
squared minus seven all of that to the
seventh power times u prime of X u prime
of X we figured out is that so the times
6x squared plus plus 10x now as you get
more practice with the chain rule you'll
recognize this faster and actually you
could do you won't have to write all of
this down you'll be able to do a lot of
it in your head you'll say okay I'm
going to take the derivative of the
outside function the blue function you
could say with respect to what I have in
the inside so if I was saying the
derivative of X to the 8th it would be
eight X to the seventh if that's with
respect to X but if I'm taking the
derivative of this with respect to the
inside well where I had the X's before I
would just have this U of X so it's
going to be eight times this to the
seventh power and I multiply that times
the derivative of the inside which is 6x
squared plus 10x